many of you called our eight news now
tip line saying affordable housing is
nearly impossible to find all right but
we have some promising news that clark
county commissioners are proving
millions of dollars today to either
build or renovate thousands of units and
that work starts now madison kimbrough
joining us live in our newsroom with
more on this madison yeah this is a big
news for thousands of valley residents
as the welcome home funds will support
construction of over 2 100 new housing
units and the rehabilitation of almost a
thousand existing apartments
good it's about time
it should have been done before they do
new apartments miss williams has lived
at buena vista springs three apartments
for two years and was pleased to find
out that relief is on the way the county
just approved nearly 120 million dollars
to go towards affordable housing that
includes new housing and upgrades to
existing units like the one williams
lives at county commissioner jim gibson
explains redoing kitchens or replacing
bathtubs and other fixtures or floors or
air conditioning you know the kinds of
things that really need to be done when
a unit is 20 years old the approved
funding includes 12.5 million dollars
for 276 new apartments for seniors and
12 million dollars to rehabilitate 236
units at the desert rose apartments home
to residents like glenda goodman who
says she was lucky to find a place here
as it's been a struggle for her as a
senior on a fixed income i had to look
three months to find something
that was affordable to me had i have not
taken this place i would have been
homeless county commissioner jim gibson
also stating that the process is set to
take place sooner rather than later as
nevadans need help now the application
process
uh is something that we're working on so
that aggressively we can get these
people in so that they can be in the
ground in months and that's that's our
goal here
now in addition four million dollars
will be allocated for 176 new apartments
for families at 4 000 desert inn road
for a full list at the new and
rehabilitated spots we have a link
attached to this story on our website at
8newsnow.com
in the newsroom madison kimbrough 8 news
now